Speaker 1: All right, these next two
stories are going to contain video clips.
Really not suitable for children. There's no gore
or anything like that, but you'll understand,
I think, as we go. So Donald Trump held a
rally over the weekend. Just another rally,
right? Who cares? Well, this one was actually one
of the most disturbing and alarming rallies I can
remember. Maybe the most alarming I've seen from
Trump because it had all the normal things. It had
the lies, and we'll look at some of the lies
it had, the delusional crowds whose ignorance
has been completely weaponized, which we will look
at, the cheering at horrible things. All of that.
But this rally in the important election state of
Iowa had some notable and key differences. First,
as Dean Obeidallah wrote for CNN, key Iowa
Republican elected officials were there
at the Georgia rally a couple of weeks ago. Trump
attacked that state's Republican leaders, this
time this weekend in Iowa, despite the insanity
of Trump for the last six years. Trump losing
the White House to Republicans in 2018, losing
the Senate and the White House in 2020, inciting
a riot on January six. Iowa's Republican leaders
were all there and they are still supporting him,
which is a very dark signal for democracy.
Chuck Grassley, as Dean Obeidallah wrote
after criticizing Trump's incitement of the Jan.
six riots, was right there in Iowa this weekend,
praising Donald Trump. So after all of it in now
October of 2021, Trump is still in control of
the party. The blind loyalty is still there,
and Trump spent the rally telling horrible,
corrosive, demonstrable lies about the
election of 2020. So let's jump right in.
Trump heavily into the xenophobia. Here he is,
saying the Afghan refugees are people will quote
soon. Be hearing about. He seems to be alluding
to soon. They're going to carry out attacks
against the U.S. and you'll be hearing about it.
Speaker 2: It was, oh, that was great. They had no
idea who was getting on those planes. We still
don't have any idea. Only three percent were
qualified to be taken to a place called the United
States of America. Is that something three percent
you're going to be hearing from those people
over the coming years in a very bad way, right?
Speaker 1: Trump then talking about his travel ban
as something to prevent people from coming here
who want to blow up our cities.
Speaker 2: The Democrat bill will also
admit every foreign national previously denied
undermine national security travel ban. Remember,
I had the travel ban. Everyone said,
Oh, what a horrible thing. I said, No,
we really don't want people in our country who are
going to blow up our cities. If you don't mind,
we don't want, we don't want 5th Avenue blown up.
Speaker 1: Now, remember that the travel ban was
actually targeted at countries that were not
source countries for people who came here
and attacked the United States. Trump then
moving on to the topic of abortion, saying
Democrats support killing babies even after birth.
Now that's murder. No one supports that. It's also
not legal. But take a listen to Trump quickly.
Speaker 2: The bill abolishes the Hyde amendment,
forcing taxpayers to fund the far less
extreme abortion agenda ripping babies
from their mother's womb right
up until the moment of birth.
And, in fact, killing babies even after
birth. You saw that in Virginia with
the governor of Virginia after birth,
Speaker 1: so that was a widely debunked
fake news story from the right couple of years
ago, actually. It's not true. The crowd maybe
doesn't know, maybe doesn't care. Who knows, but
they cheer. So then we get into the 2020 lies.
Here's Donald Trump teasing the idea that he
could. He might come back because remember,
he didn't concede. Hillary conceded. He didn't
Speaker 2: legitimate. They called it everything
in the book. It was fine. When I say it now,
here's the difference. Hillary conceded.
I never conceded. Never.
Speaker 1:
That's how you fire up a low information crowd.
Then Trump saying the corrupt media and Democrats
used COVID to put in place mail in voting. It's
hard to even exactly follow what he's saying, but
it's part of the 2020 Big Lie that he continues.
Speaker 2: These people are so corrupt the media.
Look, I don't need to do this, but the media
is corrupt. And you know what? When I started,
I'm so proud of this. Two things I proved number
one, the elections are totally corrupt in our
country, and they have been for a long time, but
never like they were this last time they used
COVID in order to cheat and rigged. And the other
thing is how dishonest the media was because they
were at 96 percent approval rating before I came
along. And now they're like, in what, the 20s?
Speaker 1: And then just to show here just to
show you how much he's in control of this crowd.
The crowd actually starts chanting Trump won as
Trump just tells lies about the 2020 election.
Speaker 2: But let's hope he does. Our country
needs it. Arizona needs it in with all of those
numbers being so horrible.
Speaker 1:
We did, as I've said before,
Trump without his followers
is really not much. But with the followers, it
is something very serious and scary. Trump then
continuing to struggle with certain
words, Minneapolis, of course,
many Annapolis. That's just par for the course.
Speaker 2: Now that's not working out too well.
You see, in Minnesota, many Annapolis there.
Speaker 1: I went to a conference in Minneapolis
once. It was weird. Really, really weird. Trump
then referring to someone as person hippity
instead of persnickety.
Speaker 2: He was
with us all the way. Every time I
needed something, you know, he's
very persnickety sometimes, right? He's tough.
Speaker 1: Persnickety, of course, means fussy
person hippity me. I don't know what that one
means. Your guess is as good as mine. Trump
then hilariously mentions, I mean, apparently
he's serious. He'll quickly finish building the
border wall. When what are you talking about?
Speaker 2: We will quickly complete the border
wall and we will end illegal immigration once and
for all. We will have to start it all over again.
Speaker 1: Remember, he was going to do the border
wall in one term. We all knew he wasn't. And he
didn't. Didn't happen. Does the crowd crowd know
that? Do they care? I have no idea. Maybe this
is that same kind of magical thinking. We talked
about where they see themselves as being in like a
war where individual facts don't matter. If Trump
says it, you've got to cheer for it because you're
part of the crowd. Is that what's going on here?
And then ultimately, Trump wound down the rally
with a completely unintelligible rant about
critical race theory, including in the military.
Speaker 2: We will ban critical race
theory in our classrooms. We will ban
that horrible, crazy critical race theory in our
military. We will ban it from our workplaces.
We will ban it from our federal, state and local
governments. It will be banned, permanently banned
and will never be allowed to come back again.
Speaker 1:
I don't even know what I can really say
about this, other than as I've said before,
I find it sort of quaint when they talk about
banning a theory. What they mean is banning
the teaching of it, right? Like, how do you
ban a theory? But it seems what they mean
is they want a gag order, which is, of course,
very authoritarian and very much a restriction
on what people can talk about, quite frankly.
So absolutely delusional event the crowd goers
as much as Trump. We're going to listen
to the crowd goers in this next segment.
But the really dangerous cherry on top is that
at this stage of the game, this late in the game,
prominent Iowa Republican Chuck Grassley still
openly supportive of Donald Trump after everything
he did. Twenty twenty four is really looking as
rough as you can imagine and will have time to
talk about it once we get beyond the midterms.
Next, let's talk about the rally attendees